In Malaysia, Malaysian investigators hold a closed-door briefing...
...on the MH370 search for the relatives of Chinese passengers.
In Chile, President Michelle Bachelet declares disaster areas in two regions of northern Chile...
...after an 8.2 magnitude earthquake.
In Afghanistan, the Afghan Army tries to clear the Sangin Valley in the Helmand Province...
...ahead of the national elections.
A police official is dead and five officers are wounded in Egypt...
...after two bombings near Cairo University.
And finally from the Philippines, Filipino activists protest China's recent attempt...
...to block the Philippine supply ship in the South China Sea.